by the studio to hang out for a couple
seconds ambassador nikki Haley bucket
list checked I get to meet you oh it's
nice to meet you my bucket list is
checked
ah now that's not true but thanks for
hanging out with us we appreciate it the
new book is out it's called with all due
respect defending America with grit and
grace if you haven't followed ambassador
Haley's career from accountant to
governor of the state of South Carolina
through some really tough times and some
great great healing we want to talk
about that all the way to obviously
being the ambassador of the United
Nations which is somewhat like herding
cats and want to get to that as well but
welcome so your own book to her how's
the book doing it's doing great I mean
people have really been very supportive
it's been a lot of fun seeing the crowds
and going out on tour and taking
pictures and signing books and you know
it's always nice to be appreciated and I
think that's the one thing as you throw
your heart and soul out into a book and
you hope people can you know just
appreciate it and and we've felt the
love definitely are you finding when
you're doing this tour I find this when
we're doing some of our stuff that the I
call them the normal people the regular
people are all okay yes and and they're
even if they don't necessarily agree
with the politics or your president or
whatever they still like your smile they
still wanna sit down here your idea
they're okay to talk it's these
characters that have lost their minds I
love being out with normal people I
really do because they're not so easily
offended and they just they're living
for the day they know exactly what
matters and what doesn't and a lot of
the stuff just rolls off their backs so
and you could have a discussion
absolutely as I said of getting all
torqued up a civil discussion that
you've spent a lot of time with people
torqued up in the last few years I
Russia and China was definitely father
would definitely qualify let's roll back
for a second you're the governor when
the horrible shooting occurred in
Charleston and we're connected to a ton
of church
is there matter fact I'll be there
Wednesday night doing an event and at
seacoast Church there oh it's a great
charity a good friends of ours and so we
were really connected to that I don't
call it a tragedy horrific act that is
the results in our tragedy just evil on
parade and in the form of racism but
also just in the form of mental illness
apparently how do you lead through
something like that as the governor as
you created an ambience of healing you
create a salve spiritually over that
over that over people that that could
have gotten riled up and out of hand
even further oh it was I mean it was a
scary time not just for what had
happened but where we were gonna go from
there and you know this was 12 people
doing what so many South Carolinians do
every Wednesday night they were going to
Bible study but on this night someone
else showed up he didn't look like them
he didn't act like them he didn't sound
like them they didn't throw him out they
didn't call the cops instead they pulled
up a chair and they prayed with him for
an hour and when they bowed their heads
in that last prayer he began to shoot
these were people like at the Lance who
had lost her daughter two years prior to
breast cancer and she had a broken heart
she would go around mother emanuel
church cleaning singing one day at a
time sweet Jesus that's all I ask of you
give me the strength to do every day
what I have to do our youngest victim
tywanza sanders had just finished
college and on that night he stood in
front of his 87 year old great aunt
Suzie and looked at the killer and said
you don't have to do this we mean no
harm to you or it was people like
Cynthia Hurd whose life motto was simply
to be kinder than necessary that's who
these people were it was the first time
there had been a shooting in a place of
worship the national media came in in
droves and they just wanted to define
the moment they wanted it to be about
racism they wanted it to be a
gun issues they want it to be about
whether we were four against the death
penalty and I just wrapped my arms
around the state because I so wanted to
protect them and and told the media
there will be a time and place where we
can have these discussions but not now
we had the funerals we had to respect
the families and I attended every single
family's funeral open caskets all of
them families falling over the bodies it
was just a terrible scene and then
within I think a day or two the shooter
came out with his manifesto and there he
was holding the Confederate flag spewing
all kinds of hate you fast forward a
couple more days and it was the first
time the killer appeared before the
judge and the families showed up and the
judge allowed them to speak and one by
one unplanned unprompted they looked at
the killer and they forgave him and that
kind of forgiveness was so overwhelming
that we didn't have riots
we had vigils we didn't have protests we
had hugs and we went through a few
really rough weeks but we held tight we
held strong the Confederate flag came
down and South Carolina and the people
of South Carolina showed what true
strength and grace looks like in the
eyes of the world with just a horrific
tragedy it was a defining moment it was
your time were you in two terms a softer
one yes - I served six years so I was in
my second term when that happened okay
in the middle of that when you took the
UN ambassador in the middle of it it
happened in 2015 okay right after yeah
and I accepted December of 2016
okay but you stepped out of a term to
accept I did so how long were the you
the UN ambassador I was there for two
years
okay did you think you were getting into
and what did you really get into so
funny because
I loved serving the state that raised me
I mean it was just the best job and
right after the president riots Priebus
the president's chief of staff called
and said even the president wants to see
you and I said for what he said well he
wants to talk to you about possibly
being Secretary of State and I said
Bryant's I can't be Secretary of State
I'm a governor and he said well he wants
to talk to you you need to show up so I
show up the next morning and I see the
president I had known him for a few
years prior and I said look I'm just not
your person I said there's too much
going on in the world you need someone
that doesn't have to have a learning
curve but I'll help you I'll support you
in any way that I can fast forward that
Friday rights calls again and says don't
say anything just listen US ambassador
to the United Nations I said right I
don't even know what the United Nations
does I just know everybody hates it and
he said well the president's gonna call
you on Monday you need to have an answer
and you know it was it wasn't the
easiest time our son was 15 our daughter
had just started college Michael and I
my husband take care of my parents are
in their 80s and my mom has Parkinson's
so they live with us
so it wasn't necessarily the best time
to move to New York but the president
called on Monday and he said all right
Nick are you gonna do this and I said
well there would need to be some
conditions in place and he said okay
what are they and I said well I've been
a governor I don't want to work for
anyone else I would want to work
directly with you so it has to be a
cabinet position he said done I said
well I'm a policy girl so I'd want to be
in the room when decisions are made so
it would need to be you know I'd want to
be on the National Security Council
he said done and I said well I'm not
gonna be a Wallflower or talking head I
need to be able to say what I think he
knew that and he said that's exactly why
I want you to do this and he was true to
his word from the first day to the last
day so our so the UN Ambassador is not
always a cabinet position it's not
always it's it's dependent on the
president typically Ronald Reagan had it
as a cabinet position he was the last
Republican president to have it as a
cabinet position and then and
president obama did have it as a cap
obsession very cool
all of this is covered and many many
other things in the book with all due
respect we're all bestsellers are sold
you can find it ambassador nikki Haley
is our guest this segment and next and
defending America with grit and grace we
were talking through the time in South
Carolina when the shooting occurred and
the healing process that she led her
state through and then President Trump
calls and she ends up being the true
chooses to be a cabinet position form of
un UN ambassador so I'm looking in from
the outside and I'm not in your world at
all and so I'm one of those people that
just kind of looks at the UN and shakes
my head and disgust and it's not a
political statement it's just a highly
ineffective a pile of money going down
the tubes and all this kind of stuff so
I'm pretty cynical about it so I'm
curious when you got there what
surprised you in a good way that you
went wow this is so much better than I
thought
the people the ambassador's typically
for other countries that is a very
senior position so usually people at the
end of their career former national
security advisors former you know
finance ministers would be or secretary
of states would be a UN Ambassador it's
the most trusted person by their
president and so it was good for me
because I realized you could get a lot
done because they could talk to their
president immediately if we wanted to
negotiate something or get something
done but just the caliber of people and
the quality of people was really
impressive there was a lot not to like
about the UN but the people were were
really impressive not not what not to
like but what was frustrating the waste
I mean the waste of money and the waste
of time and the bureaucracy of all of it
I mean that was the first thing that I
went in being an accountant myself I
always go in and look at the numbers
first because I think numbers tell a
story and you can get a lot of solutions
out of that and so you know we
immediately looked at that in the first
year we cut 1.3 billion
dollars off the budget I mean just with
low-hanging fruit and there's so much
more there I mean they they still use
elevator operators and they you know
everybody looks at the UN building and
they think oh the ambassadors are in
that big tall skinny building no that's
all staff there are thousands of people
that work in the New York UN building
and it's just staff it's and so it's a
it's a big waste it's very bureaucratic
every country wants to have their own
people working in the UN staff and so it
it can be a bit of a mess but we went in
and we really cleaned up the
peacekeeping missions we fought for just
streamlining a lot of reforms that we
wanted to see at the UN and we were able
to make a dent what changed in you
because you did that I think the main
thing that changed in me is are the
things that I saw you know right now
especially we were talking about how
toxic the political environment is and
you hear both parties referring to the
other side as evil and I've seen evil I
have been to the Democratic Republic of
Congo where they use rape as a weapon of
war I've been to South Sudan where I've
talked to crying mothers where one told
me that her baby was taken from her and
thrown into a fire and she had to eat
his flesh I've been on the Simon
Boulevard bridge watching thousands of
Venezuelans holding their babies in the
hot Sun for hours to go get the one meal
they might get that day the average
Venezuelan adult has lost 24 pounds I've
had to look at pictures of children who
died from chemical weapons from Assad
that's evil what we have in our politics
right now are different ideas and they
should be debated and people should be
passionate but we need to remember to be
grateful because on our worst day we are
blessed to be in America yeah if you
don't love this country that's the
definition of someone that hasn't
traveled I mean go to any country and
what I found was all of the ambassadors
they might have resented us I mean every
day I felt like I had to put on body
armor and there was gonna be a fight
just didn't know which country we're
gonna
fight that day but while they resented
us they all wanted to be us they all
loved that we had the freedom of speech
and freedom to worship and freedom of
expression in any way that we wanted and
they would tell me that they all loved
the idea that we had opportunities in
America like no other place and so we
have to remember that while we live in
the best most generous country in the
world it's not going to protect itself
we have to be responsible with it we
have to be responsible with how we spend
with that we have to be responsible with
how we you know allow for those freedoms
and opportunities we have to be
responsible with how we treat each other
how do you think we lost our ability to
have any any touch of a civil
conversation and the political landscape
and if we lost it that way how do we get
it back I think people were frustrated
and I think they were frustrated with
their government you know I came in
through the tea party time and people at
that point were frustrated with
governments not understanding the value
of a dollar and in the spending that has
since morphed into more of a frustration
that government's not listening and you
know I think that that gave them that
gave the rise to the passion and then
social media gave the rise to allow
people to say hateful things without
having to look the person in the eye and
so you add all that together and you've
just created you know what's a really
toxic environment and every one of us
has to be responsible you know I know
people talk about the president's not
just the president the Republican Party
it's the Democrat Party it's athletes
it's entertainers everybody needs to be
more conscious of what they say and you
know our younger generation is watching
us and they are learning from every
single thing we're doing and at some
point we have to understand that when we
fight and when we don't get along and I
talk about it a lot in the book the only
ones that win or rush in China because
they love how divided we are this is
exactly what they want is for us to be
distracted anything they can do to take
our hand off the wheel that's exactly
right so what is what do you been up to
since you left the UN well I have been
walking out talking to normal people and
not Russia and China anymore which I've
loved I spent a lot of time on the book
the reason why I wanted to write the
book now was I knew the facts would be
there I wanted the emotion to be there I
wanted people to know what the
behind-the-scenes was like at the UN and
the decisions that were made and being
governor and you know being a woman and
family and how you tackle all of that I
also started a policy group called stand
for America and that's because my son
and our daughter they don't get their
news from television or the newspaper
it's from social media and so this is a
platform where you know we try and
engage the younger people and it talks
about capitalism versus socialism and
why there's an anti-israel bias at the
UN and and what Medicare for all will
mean and so it just gives some things
there so I've been talking with some
college groups as well and just been
enjoined taking a breath it's been nice
I was raised by a powerful lady and I'm
married to one and I raised two more and
Rachael Cruz is one of our daughters is
one of our best-selling authors that
speaks regularly and we talk about this
kind of thing all the time and you talk
about in the book and this is a fabulous
phrase as a woman what does it mean to
know the power of your voice you know
it's not use it all the time but it's
knowing when to use it and when you use
it make it mean something and I think a
lot of times it's not how much you say
it's what you say and so I've always
tried to tell everyone to use the power
of their voice you can move mountains
with your voice if you use it for good
sometimes when people find their voice
they they have so much anger that they
can't stop talking or saying the wrong
thing at the wrong times just they're
spewing that's different than finding
your voice that's exactly right
look I saw I heard a lot of spewing at
the United Nations so I can tell you
that that that happens but our words
matter we see it on the 24-hour news
cycle thing anything to say and so they
have to say something and it doesn't
come out well exactly right it's not
it's not well thought out and
and you know when you've got an avatar
instead of someone signing their name to
their hate on online digital courage
which is actually cowardice it goes
there so ambassador thank you for taking
time to come by we're honored to have
you in our home
oh this has been a lot of fun thank you
so much ambassador nikki Haley the book
is with all due respect defending
America with grit and grace and having
better it's been a little time with her
I'm sure that's exactly what you'll find
between the covers this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]